there are certain things that are like
can you explain to me some of the
unwritten rules or code of the porn game
because you had shared some information
that we won't talk about off camera the
last time I saw you some details about
your video or Lena's video rather what
Jason loved that we won't talk about but
there is a code right like and and I
think you said that Jason love maybe
broke the code a little I mean nobody
has ever explicitly told me that there's
a Code but I definitely feel like
there's an expectation that you keep it
a little bit gangster in terms of the
whole point thing because if you're on
set you're going to see a lot of weird
[__] you know you're going to see dudes
having to jerk their dick off for 45
minutes to get hard you're gonna see
guys having a pop Viagra cigarette hard
you're going to see you know girls who
have over there on their period so they
have to go and like shove some [__]
sponge thing in there and to clean out
whatever kind of stuff might be in there
there's all kinds of [__] and like I
realize this because I like the one time
I did a an anal threesome with Riley
Reid and my girl back in the day in our
backyard which is kind of hard to
imagine now we probably wouldn't do that
these days since we have like a family
and everything but you know there was
some some leakage some [__] flying you
know it's happened and you know I had a
turret on my knee at one point and stuff
and then I went on the podcast that week
and I just talked about it and my girl
had to tell me like yo like I don't
think girls are gonna necessarily want
to do anal threesomes with us if you're
just going to be airing out the grossest
things that happened and I was like that
is a really good point and so anything
like messy that happens on set I feel
like it's kind of our responsibility to
not talk about it if a dude can't get
hard it's like we're not gonna clown
them we're just gonna kind of ignore it
to me also probably within the porn
guy's code should be like you don't like
you know especially if a [__]
well-known dude like me is gonna let you
[__] their wife on camera for porn
content you should probably not be
critical of him in any way or you might
be respectful yeah you know don't do
this weird like dick comparison thing or
whatever even though obviously yeah you
have a huge hog but it's like you just
don't need to say that and I feel like
now if we shoot with any more guys that
will be very much a conversation it's
like okay this is the this is the way
that we can talk about this and this is
the way we can and we need this you know
to stay on the same page in terms of all
this but I feel like he he he got a lot
of hate for maybe not beating it up
right and that I I guess he probably had
never dealt with that before so he was
probably trying to compensate for that
by clarifying and like on your end
you're probably like thank you
I mean thanks for not like yeah you've
seen like some of these [__] scenes
This Guy's in he's [__] you know and
I thought about that after like oh wow
like I kind of got off easy there
because you know I didn't really think
about what kind of sex they were going
to be having beforehand and the the
scene that they did was very much like
very you know a a an easy entry point
for me in the sense that it was not some
Brian Gosling Hot Shot Hot Shot hookups
or whatever the [__] that is it's just
like the most aggressive type of porn
obviously so yeah I mean I guess he he
did kind of do me a favor in that regret
shout out to uh is he gonna come on the
podcast I don't know I don't know what
the [__] he's doing I heard he like flew
to Toronto to do six Buzz so who knows
what they're gonna ask him oh he's just
he's just he's he's probably this
probably raised his profile to like a I
mean he was already a pretty popular guy
I'm sure yeah but the weird thing in
porn is like you could be really popular
in porn and then you're still kind of
like a regular person to most people
right especially if you're a dude yeah
oh especially if you're a dude and even
like you know sometimes I think about
that like I can't get a little baby
interview I can't get a cardi interview
or Uzi vert interview but it's no
problem for me to get a savannah Bond
piece of content or Angela White or all
these like super huge girls are much
more approachable and like you know
humble than the top rappers you know
what um
what is the like expectation now moving
forward is this is are you guys gonna
make her doing the dude scene a regular
thing we're definitely gonna do more of
it but I would say like the frequency is
probably the thing that's kind of Up For
Debate that we're still kind of figuring
out and like you know there's some stuff
that I really don't mind at all like
like I probably would have been real
nervous about it before but like me
[__] her with another guy
I don't really like feel any type of way
about that anymore like that's no
problem like I'll definitely do that
would you do the would you do the DP
yeah I feel like that's on the bucket
list but then that's like a dick on dick
yeah and you know it's like I'm not
gonna [__] a dude Kev listen I don't
want you to [__] dude but if you're
gonna do the DP there's no way that your
guys's dicks don't touch or ball slap or
just you're crossing swords I got to do
it one time before I die okay and you
might I mean you got to do I mean
obviously you're married so it's got to
be my leg bumps another dude's leg it's
like whatever we all been in the gym
locker room before or whatever but also
like I don't know like it's got to be a
homie I think it's got to be something
I'm like real cool with